I'm really into Gwyneth Paltrow's goop
nurse I don't know who when it outro is
if this is the same woman who told me to
steam my vagina and I'm on board
well I smoothie in quotation we don't
really know I don't think so
maca powder I think I've heard of after
wanting Agartha
oh she was sounds like my grandpa's name
cordyceps is that like a Pokemon action
dust Beauty does experimental
I think it smells pretty good I smell
the almond I think it smells like here
we go
in her Gwen's oh no oh god okay whew
there's nothing sweet about this
smoothie that was a lot more watery than
I thought saying you had a blender and
you put cocoa pebbles in it you put some
chalk I think there's like sediments at
the bottom kind of tastes like how my
yoga studio smells I want to like not
think about it and that's what I'm say
you got a jug which dusted we have do I
detect a hint of brain dust in here I'm
gonna say Sextus no I think I got a
newbie desk I don't know why I just feel
like I might be brainless Oh see if me
see it's working I feel like this is
healthy it just should be disguised and
hey would it hurt to just like throw an
orange juice on this like when come on
or add some vodka to it but here's to
health you know I feel like my body is
accepting these nutrients that didn't no
one needed she's gonna be the oldest
living person and she's gonna be like
suckers
I told yourself finish it finish it no
way oh god every time I swear as I can